se habla de muchas fallas como por
ejemplo desvío de dinero faltas de vías
de escape y refugio estamos hablando de
una tragedia que pudo haberse evitado
si son muchas las causas de esta
tragedia pobreza construcciones
irregulares abandono la falta de
provocación de las autoridades
implicadas y pocos fondos de adaptación
al clima agregados al cambio climático
petrópolis es una ciudad que es
susceptible de sufrir fuertes lluvias
porque está en la montaña pero las
ocupaciones irregulares en laderas muy
pronunciadas está liando la vegetación
nativa muy cerca de ríos y arroyos o en
zonas de protección permanente son
factores que condicionan el impacto
grave de estos eventos climáticos
nicole como está preparada brasil para
eventos de este tipo hace 10 años por
ejemplo la región serrana de río también
900 personas perdieron la vida en un
episodio similar y desde el año pasado
las lluvias vienen afectando estados
como bahía sao paulo y minas gerais
si desafortunadamente las autoridades no
están
listas en
resolver estos problemas porque hay una
legislación sobre ordenación del
territorio pero no se cumple o no hay
inspección entonces en 2011 la ciudad de
petrópolis teresópolis y nueva friburgo
toda la región de bío fue muy afectada
por las fuertes lluvias hubo un avance
porque hubo instalación de sirenas la
vigilancia climática y de movimiento de
masas pero lo que pasa es que las zonas
de alto riesgo
no están con las de equipo los equipos
de protección civil preparadas equipadas
y con dinero y recursos para actuar
entonces cuando hay un aviso de un
desprendimiento ocasional como hubo en
petrópolis el lunes dos días antes de la
tragedia lo que debería ser hecho es la
reubicación de la población
eso no fue pecho
puede tomarse esto como un llamado a
tomar acciones frente al cambio
climático en brasil tal vez
sí seguro que sí porque la verdadera
tragedia es dejar la población más
vulnerable a riesgo de muerte en estas
ocasiones estas personas pierden todo lo
que poseen y la pobreza hace más que
empeorar entonces las autoridades lo que
tienen que pasar en brasil es un
incremento del fondo de adaptación
climática e incremento de
monitoreamiento tanto climático cuanto
de movimientos de masas y también
mejora del equipo de la protección civil
y los recursos para que puedan actuar
y también tiene que ser agregar un plan
de
reubicación de la población que vive en
zonas de riesgo porque en 2011
petrópolis tuvo esta tragedia y la
situación en 2011 50% de la población
vivía en zonas irregulares y la
situación solo peor o hasta hoy